This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay,
Jean?
Yeah,
it is a cool sound.
Um,
so I added shows last week in Boise,
Idaho and the, uh, the boys,
you theater and it sold out.
The first one sold out.
So it's at the Egyptian,
sorry,
the Egyptian theater in
Boise on October 5th.
So we added a second show
doing a late show. Now,
if you didn't get tickets to that first
one, try to get tickets to this one.
Try at, um, uh, what else? Uh,
there's a few tickets left for
the third show in New Orleans.
September 29th, uh, brass
balls, beach, Florida.
The West Palm Beach Improv has
shows or tickets that is in August.
And uh, where did I add? I added
a, or I have a show in Sacramento,
October six.
I have a show in Fresno,
October 26 and in Bakersfield,
October 27th,
those are on sale.
Jack me off fill Florida November 2nd.
Orlando, Florida. Yeah. Yeah.
November 3rd is a whore.
Lando. And then fill her up.
Delphia at the Merriam theater.
November 16th has been added.
So, uh, those tickets are all at Tom.
cigarette.com/tour.
Jean,
you're in Los Angeles. Oh, you know what?
You got to do this all over again
because your, your mic is muted.
Yeah, I can hear you too, but you're not
truck now. Yeah, my mom. Yeah.
Yeah. Now you're back. Yeah.
I'll just do my dates over. That's
all I did for so far. Yeah, go ahead.
Uh, hold on. Let me pull
them up. Okay, hold on.
I'll give you a just for people to
go, they're going to hear an edit. Um,
this is, uh, Christina,
her mic is now unmuted.
So now she can talk to dream come
true. Tom And I, you did Mike.
So May 31st, uh, here in Los Angeles.
We don't have one for Los Angeles moms,
moms, Angeles. I mean, it is like the
center. Yeah, it is. Hmm. Anyway, uh,
so May 31st eight o'clock show,
it's going to be in the belly room
at the comedy store with my favorite
comedians. It's going to be
myself, right? We got Ryan Sickler,
Aka sickle cell, Sam Tripoli,
Steve Simone and Joanie Coyote.
They're going to be my special guests
and it's going to be a blast tickets
available now on Christina p
online. It's a tiny, tiny room.
It's intimate for a reason.
I can't tell you what the reason is,
but it's very excited when you get to
tell reasons as soon as things are signed,
I think,
but it's very exciting to amaze and
you'll see you're going to be a part of
something. Very cool. So get
those tickets now. November,
really Tom, November 24, man,
Diego at the House of Blues. Uh,
tickets are going quickly on that one.
And then December 8th and Jude Orc
titties at the Gramercy theater.
Just a handful of tickets left on that.
Christina p online for, for all the links.
Thank you. I love you. All right.
There you have it. And there you go.
So distracting that you
belched during my thing.
I think people are very upset. I'm
sure they are. All right. It's fixed.
Okay.
Men are now much better now.
Um,
let's see you.
Thank you to Scott for a
walking us through that.
I think it's fixed. Let's see. Let's
see if it's fixed. I think it is fixed.
Try it out. Yup. Um, I
love you again. Okay.
You're supposed to.
Sounds good. Do we have an
opening clip? Reciprocate.
You're supposed to reciprocate.
What? That's a big word.
I don't know what that means.
[inaudible] supposed to give it back.
All right.
I love you again.
What?
How did you stop?
How are you going to stop? What did,
how did, what did I do to make you stop?
All right. I love you. I
love you again. All right.
Lot of really amazing stuff to get into
on this show. I mean, really, really,
really good stuff. Are you ready? Yeah,
let's do it. Let's get into this show.
Here you go.
Hi. I'll make this brief. My name
is Shannon. Why your shipment?
I'm looking for girls for pussy.
I love to eat pussy.
Okay.
Don't bring anyone loving. Well, welcome.
It looks like he likes
to eat a lot of stuff.
We keep getting these cool
guys that produce videos.
How are they finding this? I don't
know and it's a very unique and whoever
is sending these in, I want to thank
you from the bottom of my heart.
This is exactly what gets me going.
Me Too.
And it meets all the criteria and
Albert. Excellent. Your mom crops, video,
portrait mode, tight. Uh, Y,
y wall background,
ceiling.
What normally happens is they hold that
camera away and you kind of get a little
too much, you know, space. He
went the opposite. Too much face.
He's holding his phone right here.
He's all face.
It's almost like he's telling you a secret
that he likes pussy. It's disgusting.
I don't want him to know that close and
he's got acne and most of these guys
need to know that all girls know that
you want Pussy Tommy and they don't want
to hear you saying that. They never
want to hear you say that. That's true.
It is kind of a given. Yeah, he does.
He's not shocking anybody with this news.
No, no. He's fucking, they all like it.
We all want it. Yeah. Well you
know, or some version of whatever.
He is so damned gross.
If you're in Africa,
you're looking for some action
kind of whisper to you.
Hello?
Talk.
Call me one to five or seven or text me.
Oh,
my dad's the one six three
Oh, he gave two different numbers.
Gout. What's with the, why does he call?
I know the whisper talks also. He's on
the drew list, please. Missouri Fat Guy.
Pussy Hound.
But then what's the drew list
up to how many we have for him?
Let me find it first. There's gotta be
some new. This is like new stuff for true.
This is, this is fucking not normal. I
don't know where it is. Where did it go?
You're too drew list. Maybe I'm
on the other side. Here it is.
Missouri fat girl. How many other things
around there for drew? We could should,
we should have them in pretty soon.
Yeah, it looks good. Well, one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven. Oh,
that's a nine 10 1111
with the Missouri Fat Guy.
Are you serious things
that he hasn't seen yet?
Fresh material like this show
is grist for the mill of crazy.
Yeah, we've got the mill. Oh my God.
It knows that many. Yeah, of course.
Okay. Yeah. Dr Drew,
please come back. We got a,
Oh, I keep telling him I keep
forwarding him these clips.
Is he saying it's usually an emoji with
vomit of some kind needs you send them
the clip itself? No, I sent him the
teaser of last week and we were like,
this one's for him. And um,
he's, he's excited. He's
like, can't wait. Can't wait.
Alright. And it's said Barf
Emoji. Excellent. Excellent.
Let's see what this into. I
don't need no, I'd love to know.
Yeah, we know. Anytime.
Machine out of Jerky, Huh? Oh,
I want to curly. Can Roll a blunt with
her pussy. Oh, text me or call me.
My name is Chela and call
me tangible. Bye. Bye.
Wait, I'm hearing a
little Damien back. Um,
let's look at the Spaghetti
spaceship talk. Yeah,
I think Bruce is going to talk about
these eyes. Yeah. Blog. The uh,
level of volume and the boys.
Yeah. Well I'm also like, I again,
there's a little delusional made a beef
jerky and the thing and then roll a
blunt with your pussy. Yeah, it's
not possible. Not Possible. No.
No matter how talented you are,
you busy. Yeah. Why the low talk?
What is that his sexy voice?
I don't know.
No, I want to barely can roll
a blunt with her blessing.
That's, that's pretty, he's
trying to meet. That's,
but that's his deliberate sexy time boys.
Yeah.
Saying any time machine out of beef Jerky,
sex swing time machine at a beef jerky.
It's really not. Does that even mean?
What does that mean sir? Oh, think
anyone called or texted him. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. And I think that
maybe now they will. Well, that's,
I'm saying you and I have been giving
these guys a great platform yet.
We don't give out their numbers.
Obviously. It's a fine line.
So they can find them. We
uh, uh, the Meth, that guy
took it video down. Why? Why?
Yeah. I wonder why people found
them and they're like, hey man,
I want to see that Dick get bigger.
That's the thing about our,
uh,
listeners is that they are so
good at finding these people.
You can't hide from the Mommy's yes.
That they are a harnessed force and
they should never be matched with,
you know? Yeah man. Yeah. Quite a force.
Oh my God. I, I don't want to forget.
So that's why I'm jumping into
this right now. What's that? Um,
I did it. I did it. I did it.
I went ahead and against your wishes.
Um, hold on. Oh boy.
Against your wishes. No
neuropathy. Now your apathy issues,
he just said,
I'm not sure why that's relevant
to his discussion of what,
when his brother comes so hard.
Yeah. With no known neuropathy.
[inaudible] neuropathy hinder his ability
to come rather than bolster it boost
his ability to come hard. You know what
I'm saying? Like his argument is, yeah,
there's no known neuropathy that would
be an advantage is what I'm thinking to
his coming so hard.
It's all the math.
So why I mentioned the neuropathy, I
don't know baby smokes meth. I mean,
what are you trying to do here?
I'm just trying to make logical sense
out of the argument. That's your problem.
My problem with crazy is my whole life
I've tried to understand it and I just,
you can't, you can't understand it. You
just gotta let it go. You dared me and,
and double dog dared me and
said, it's not possible. Uh,
I didn't say that. A, you said it's
not a good idea. It's not possible.
And I went and pulled the trigger anyway.
Oh boy. It's the four stroking tee shirt
from,
I'll see you at your mom's house. Oh
boy. We went with the approach of,
uh,
having a golf clubs.
A lot of people were telling me, oh,
motorcycles have four stroke engines,
but I have no one. No, I
wouldn't know that. Well, the,
I just was just like, yeah,
I don't,
so it says your mom's house for
stroke gang, don't math with us,
which is pretty funny.
I like the tag.
Yeah, it's pretty great.
I'm trying to find a,
I want to find the gentleman
that designed it for us. Uh,
to me it's Jeffrey Miles. Jeffrey
Jeffrey. Thank you very much. Uh,
says your mom's house. And then on that
bottom part it says, don't mess with us.
Which was a suggestion from somebody for
stroke gang. So it's in the store. Um,
I'm going to be selling
about five or seven of these.
Let's show Christina what time it is
and prove to her that for stroke gang it
can be for the masses.
My prediction [inaudible]
Lotta Xcels not at all.
Not a lot of uh, female cuts being
sold. I can go and mail only on this.
I think the,
okay,
when that's a smart idea because you're
not going to see a lot of females,
female side necessarily.
Trolls mediums are going to seem larger
sizes being so like you're full of it.
But yeah. Um, I would be,
I would be so surprised if I saw a woman
out of your mom's house event or one of
our standup shows wearing this.
I would not be surprised.
This is the difference between
you and me. Okay. Well I believe,
I'd like to get some numbers on these
because this is the rub rub shirt and no
offense to the designer because he
tweeted me and he was like, I'm,
I can't believe you. Yeah, that was funny.
I was joking. But the design is fine.
I'm not saying anything. I just
think the concept, the idea of your,
of a com beard on a comedian's face,
it's a little aggressive and I'm thinking
four strokes till someone comes hard
again. A little aggressive.
And they did the play on,
they put golf clubs there. Oh,
I got it. No, I understand the joke.
It's very clever. But uh, you know,
what does it mean? It's about, well now
like an inside thing where like
somebody who just walks by,
someone in that shirt, it's like, Oh
God, I got it. A golf thing, you know?
Yeah. You're laughing at my reaction.
You know what's great about it?
It happens every, every episode and you
get mad every time. I know. It's terrible.
It's so funny.
You're like Charlie Brown when he goes
to kick the ball and then Lucy takes it
away. No. And he's like, why
did I keep trying anyways? Um,
disgusting,
vile
bye. Sees it. And they go, oh, that's
a golf friend. But then if it's a,
somebody that's in the know,
they know that it's a meth smoking,
that's a meth pipe right
under the golf clubs.
Yeah. But meant to look like a, a t with
a ball kind of upside down, you know?
Yeah.
You know me really funny because
doesn't Your Dad Golf? Yeah.
Maybe we could get him a shirt.
Oh, I'll definitely send them one.
You buddy at a golf shirt.
What's this for? Stroking cow.
So at four strokes would
imply we gotta get it.
I'm on the show soon.
He, uh, he's on a trip,
right? Four strokes would imply that you
can get the ball in the hole and four,
well it would, well, I mean it would
just, it doesn't necessarily
suggest that it's just, you know,
a stroke is, uh, you
know, a swing of it. Um,
three strokes for strokes.
So I think it would just suggest to
a golf person that it's just, yeah.
Golf Lingo. You want me super funny
is if golf nerds did buy it. No,
I had no idea. Like, he's so
funny. He, to the driving range,
Dad boners wearing it.
What's the forest stroke that you and
your friends you go play golf? Uh,
yeah. Well, uh,
have fun selling those five
shirts and view so wrong on this.
Let's see what mentally ill women
you know are into that kind of stuff.
I'm telling you,
it's in the store now. March method,
merchant method.com. So slash Tom Segura.
Um, we did our, uh, so grow, we
did an overnight to get away.
Yeah. For one night. What we do is, uh,
we take her some and put them in the
dog crate, put a bowl, some waters,
fresh water,
don't get upset.
We leave him diapers were like change
yourself and then, sure. Uh, we, uh,
we just leave him for like a day again.
Please say that you're joking.
So the child services doesn't
come investigate. Kidding.
It's less than a day.
We did them for like 18 hours.
Okay. Um, no, we have a,
he's watched. Don't worry about it. No.
Yeah, well it, the cigarettes and his,
his booze and then we go overnight.
It's just what something we
do every once in a while.
And we went to a nice place. We
spent the night out, but, uh,
first we went to their spa and did
like nice mommy treatment at the spa.
And, um, beforehand,
before we left the house,
actually it was like mid day you
had ordered a Mediterranean lunch.
Yeah. And you were like trial this stuff.
And I go, okay. And it was really good.
It was it an Israeli or is it yeah,
Sydney. Yeah. Yeah, Mediterranean Diet.
I was reading how healthy it is and I'm
really into sour tastes right now being
preggers. Yeah. So, you know,
it's like a fucking Hamas and
chicken kebabs and stuff like that.
I had, you know, had had breakfast
and I was, I was like, yeah,
but I'll try these and I've took
a couple of bites of things,
really fresh egg plant that
fresh salads and mix, right.
Diced tomatoes, all fresh.
Very good. Really good.
And then of course like a homemade fresh
hummus. Hamas, I think he's homeless.
Yeah, I, I
had that homos and um,
if you bites then a few
more or less really good.
And we drive to the place and um,
we check in together.
I go in my room,
I lay on this table and a
therapist comes in and was like,
okay here, you know, whatever,
like relax, have a nice treatment.
And then as she like changes
the light in the room,
my stomach goes through.
Oh, I was like, oh my God.
And like, you know when
you, I could feel it.
The feeling from my gut to my asshole,
I'm looking through that donut that your
face is in and I, my eyes widened. I go,
oh my God,
it's a catch it quick and I
just squeeze my cheeks so hot.
I spent the first 15 minutes just like
this and that donut like in a full panic.
And then eventually it just
went back up inside me.
It's interesting cause
I had a panic fart too,
cause that Mediterranean
food really creates a lot of
gas and I just client just
hard as I can, which is very hard for
me. Um, but then it just disappeared.
Yeah.
Now here's the nice part is that the
minute you stand up after the massage,
it all comes out. Oh it is. Here's
the thing, and you forgot about it.
That's what happened. You know, it's
like a 90 minute treatment massage.
So when, uh, when you're, when
it's like, okay, it's done.
You kind of have that drunk post
massage feeling where you're like, whoa.
And she was like, oh, they're
waiting outside with water,
their water. And I sit up
and you're like, Oh man,
you sit on the table for a second,
kind of gather yourself,
put your robe on. Like, oh man.
And then asthma about to walk out.
I go, Huh, I got the fart again.
And now you feel no pressure, no fear.
And it's just, it's like it built,
it grows, it grows and then
it comes out so fast. Yeah.
And so effortlessly,
but also with more substance and purpose
has really some meaning behind it.
You can't stop it if you want it to.
At that point, it was like a
second massage has to happen.
Now what's really neat is where I was
climbing up some stairs with you to go
back to our room and there
was a gaggle of young girls,
little 1213 year old tea.
We're not 12, 13? No. Uh,
how old are those slots? No,
like 17, 18, 19 like, yeah,
they're older tables sluts. Okay. Yeah,
they were total slots. Now they look,
they look tiny.
Everyone looks so young to me now.
They're not 12th night and they were
walking. I climb steps slowly now.
So they're like all kind of going
past and I let out the biggest fart.
Believe it. Here's
what's interesting. Okay.
Here's why I wrote it down for
topic today because if you recall,
the Cincinnati fart happened when I was
six months pregnant and Cincinnati and
that, what room do we, six one
eight or eight oh eight. Yeah.
We couldn't figure it
out. And, and it came to,
it came to my attention that pregnancy
farts for me are more powerful.
They smell exactly like what I
have just eaten. I, um, the day
I had some Broccoli and Le and beef
stew, I farted, like an hour later,
it's smelled exactly like the beef stew
in the Broccoli. He was so crazy intense.
And so I allowed that tremendous for
it on the stairs. And I was like,
this is one of the nice things
about being pregnant is the volume,
the ferocity,
the years probably people that had really
heard and seen you do that would have
been that poor woman. You get
so much empathy as a, you know,
you think they take mercy on us.
Oh definitely.
Like I had done in the
pig that had been like,
oh that that nicely. They have no
idea what a savage you are no idea.
That's the best part about being
a lady is that nobody knows it's,
it's my secret,
our secret
and have a rnt and no that was great.
And then here's the other thing that
we might, God we're at a nice place,
you know, it's our one night out
for like, I dunno the month or two,
we never go out to dinner anymore.
Like we're in bed by
eight o'clock watching TV.
Like the dinner doesn't happen. So make
a reservation at a nice restaurant.
Really Nice restaurant and we eat it fine.
We look at the menu and we're like,
it's going to be a great meal. And then
especially because you're pregnant,
cause I actually, I follow the lead
a lot. Like I try to be a good boy,
but if there's a pregnant woman eating
and saying I can only resist so much.
And so it's like there's a
few hours and you're like,
well I got to eat something. Like I need
a snack. I could, we had a good two,
two hours and 45 minutes before a
dinner reservation at this point.
Here's the thing,
we usually dinner like at five with our
kid and our dinner reservation was for
seven 45 which is for me,
that's pajamas at bedtime.
So five you're like, you're like, oh I got
to wait almost three hours. You got to,
got to order something.
So we pull up the room,
the in room dining menu. Yeah.
And we, you start ordering
beet salad, cheese, careless smarties.
And then what was the other thing?
Oh the chips and Guac.
That's always the nail and the confidence
that that was bad. I mean it was good.
But anyways, they bring it up and
then it starts picking up cookies too.
Yeah. Oh No, they brought a
whole thing of different cookies.
What the fuck is this? Oh, just welcomes.
It's just a gift from the staff.
Oh my God. Yeah. I just, I dunno,
all of a sudden I'm looking at you.
I'm like,
supposed to have dinner in an
hour and you're like, yeah, oh,
I think we're going to skip appetizers.
I'm like, yeah. I think, yeah.
I ended up being a great meal
that we only ate even when I,
when I ordered dinner, the guy was like,
he sides. I was like, nope. He's like,
it's not that big of go. It's
fine. I'd never do that. I
was like, no, no. It's good.
We're such 80th and that's such a nice
place. And we never really go out tonight.
We don't go to a nice places anymore
and like, we totally blew it, dude.
We blew it on Calamari and chips
and salsa and the chips in gloss.
So it was a fun night though. Super
Fun. Yeah, but I was like, dude,
you take it for at, Huh? Oh yeah, of
course. What did you drink? I drank.
Um, oh. I tried one of their signature
cocktails. I didn't even know that.
Yeah. And then, uh,
I had a glass of wine
after that crazy rep brows.
I'd be carried back to
the room. Sure, sure.
Well, you know what's so funny to you
and I are, this is why we're married,
been together for so long is that
we both liked the same things,
which is laying down and then eating.
Yeah.
Well it makes for a good relationship
watching stuff. Farming land,
the end of the same stuff, man.
Patten dogs. You know what I mean?
This is something I want you
to think about since, um,
we're going to have another baby soon.
Also,
I'm making use today a bit of a stink.
I've a baby nappies asexuality expert
claims parents must ask permission before
changing their child's nappy.
Yeah. It's a foreign or word for it. So
it's the idea that we should ask
this child to be about for consent
to change. Yeah. In Carlson blades,
consent must be given by the child
before they dirty nappies removed.
He or she is on the ABC
suggesting how to go about it.
I'm going to change a nappy now.
Is that okay?
Of course the baby is not going to
respond. Yes, mom. That's awesome.
I'd love to have my nappy changed,
but if you leave a space and wait for
body language and ways to make eye
contact,
then you're letting that child know that
their response matters and live in Glen
in that child run away
from the change table,
right? That's right. That's right.
I was going to say shit on it.
It's such, what's going on? It's
worth shit. What the fuck is it?
You know what's wrong is that people
don't think there's objective reality
anymore. Everybody's living
in their own version of it,
and so whatever you say is right,
it doesn't matter.
There's no objective shit happening.
The thing is,
this woman had it right on the head.
You ever try to change a diaper on a
screaming infant who's wet and miserable?
Never give consent one out of half the
time when a kid can't even respond,
but they're usually like, no, no, and
you're like, you have shit on you.
Well this morning. Yeah.
It takes 10 minutes just to
wrangle the toddler and uh,
to convince him to stop playing for
five seconds. Yes. It's, it's a,
it's a fucking nightmare,
man. And an infant, someone
who can't even really talk,
respond. Oh my God. That is the dumbest
thing I've ever fucking heard. Fuck.
An eight week old.
Is it okay with you?
This dumb bitch and I have never had
a kid in her life. [inaudible] stupid.
Basically. It's caused quite a stir.
Some slam. His concept is left lunacy.
Yes. Carson has definitive comments
saying the idea around consent is about
empowering children with their rights
and protecting them from sexual abuse.
Oh, okay. Well here's the
thing. You just tell the kid,
mommy and daddy change your your day
day. Yeah. And it, you know, nobody else.
That's it.
Or if someone touches your eat,
why can't you just have a conversation
with your kids is what I'm saying?
Because what you're talking about like
stupid idiot kids that can't speak though.
She's talking about babies.
I've got a seat.
Same month old. You do two photo.
It's cool. Cool. It's cool.
Yeah. She can see her point. Oh, okay,
well monitor. It'll go po
says no. It was a single time.
You're not respecting
her consent. Oh, I know.
I liked these. Yeah, yeah, of course.
These keeper. Real man. Yeah. Um,
all I know. Yeah. You're
not respecting her consent.
Change that baby's nappy.
Well then I guess diaper changing is a
sexual event. Is that what they're saying?
I don't know. I'm going to change a nappy
now. He said, okay. Is that it? Okay.
I mean, you're not touch, you know what I
mean? It's not a sexual, I understand the,
the,
the kind of the logic of like,
can I pull your pants down essentially
and do the, you know, wipe you up.
But you know what, this is a, it
is, is it's madness. Yes. It's,
it's absolutely madness that you would
think to ask a baby for consent to,
I mean, the fact that we're even
having this conversation. Yeah.
Well I'll tell you what else is
insanity. Uh, remember that gender,
was it Holland?
And she was asking the two year old what
gender the two year old felt that day.
And it's like the kid doesn't even
understand the fucking question.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And it's like they don't know how
to even think in that way yet. No,
it's not even that's not happening.
Uh,
I'll tell you who's not into
giving consent for everything.
Couple a number of the things they do.
Let me show you this gentleman
after one of his fights in
prison have to be the guy so bad.
I took a blue no sane and just
feeling this in no what I'm saying.
Nothing.
And it went from there, man.
Yeah, it went from no sure.
Became well known.
I would like a live in laser
does a respect everybody on this.
Everybody do you know about
me or disrespect of as Dasa,
you know what I'm saying?
And get crazy.
So he's got his own alter
ego. Good for him. I mean, I,
I can't say I wouldn't try to
do the same in prison. Well,
why don't you hear a little bit
more about what dark side does.
Kelly says when others crossing
you will not only hurt them,
humiliate them as well. We warn
you, it's description is disturbing.
I told you SPEC. You know what I'm saying?
I told this, I might put more food.
It took me to put a wound or saying
I'll take me.
You know what I'm saying? You know what
I'm saying? Everybody don't mess with me.
No reason why by lead them after I
get in physical contact with them,
I learned an improvement from a 25 year
vision. I seen an old car and beat,
you know when he knocked the gap?
No Sin.
He took a finger stuck in the Buddha
Hall. No what I'm saying. And they did it.
So when that man crazy,
the Megan was sticking a finger
Buddha holes and we going to kill him.
Leave him alone. No. Beethoven.
I alert. Yes. I learned from
it. Makes Sense. It does make sense.
It's scary as shit though, right? Yeah.
I mean that this guy is terrifying, but
that's why he, that's his signature move.
Yeah. He's telling you, I'm uh,
I'm uh, if you fuck with me,
I'm going to put my finger in your butt.
I'm going to put my finger up your butt.
If you fuck with me. He's the
backside guy. Oh, he's smart.
He knows what he's doing. It's called
marketing. It's called branding.
Tom Get on board. I don't know,
man. It's um, that's intense.
So nobody's talked to them. No, no fucks
with him. And they, you, you realize that.
You probably get the warning when you
get that he's, he gets, he's like,
yeah. Hey Man. And then he, if you're new,
you ask them about you like that to
show me his finger. Was that all about,
I'm like, well, the dark side
and he's got a real dark side.
He will, a dork set. He'll knock you out.
They help put his finger up your ass.
Just be aware of the thumb.
If you get on his bad side.
He just crazy Yulia Salada you name it.
Don't matter what you do.
Are you going to get you
love it?
Yeah. I mean, look, you got a credit,
this guy for some creativity here.
He's got a great hook.
He's got a great way of
protecting himself. Yeah. I
mean, he's kind of brilliant.
I think this is brilliant, really. Dude,
if you are in prison with all
these fucking hard dudes. Yeah.
And you got them all afraid of you because
you're going to shove your finger and
you're in their butts.
Yeah. It's brilliant.
I feel like he would just be giving his
idea to all these other guys though.
I mean, no, what's the stop? The
other guy should be like, oh,
that's what I'm going to do to,
you know.
So they're both trying to put their
fingers in each other's exactly.
You're fighting. Yeah, exactly.
You can't take another inmate's
calling card. That's not cool.
I mean what's going to stop you?
You're a convict. You're uh, you know,
remember this, this is also a prison
guy. I gave him to Greece. Yeah.
That guy's terrible.
I tell him now this one,
I'm on his finger sticking in his
eighties and you know what I'm saying?
Kind of like fuck yourself.
Yeah.
That's even scarier though
to tell somebody to put their
finger in their own. Oh,
this one's, that one's
super menacing. Yeah.
Cause you know it's leading
to a Fox. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. Yeah. Yeah. Cause he's like,
you got to lubricate yourself
so I don't get in trouble.
Wasn't that the reasoning?
Imagine like likes to fuck his seal.
That's a motto is fine. It is a is,
you know what I'm fucking saying?
Yeah. Well this guy, it's
just a finger in the stank.
He done it when you're knocked out.
Yeah. So it's fine. Like there's no fire.
What are you talking about? You're
knocked out. You're not gonna feel it.
You'll feel it afterwards. It's
just a finger gently. Well,
it's a thumb on a, you know, you're
already unconscious. So what?
Saying no. Saying Salsa.
Salsa.
Wow.
Got It. He's got it. He's
got the right idea. This guy,
you're a fan of dark side.
Hey man,
if I were in prison and if I were smart
enough to come up with a hook like that.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean this guy's
a genius. A genius. Dark sizes.
Thanks.
Okay.
Flavor fleet.
Yup.
No, say no. Say No. Say
No. Say No. No.
It's been a while since we've
had a montage. Super Cut.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that.
Yeah. That was pretty great.
Thanks. Dark sighting. God,
that would be the worst guy
to see on the yard. Oh my God.
Best if your cell mate with
someone like that? Nope.
I don't think he has a cellmate.
No, I don't think so either.
I think they know better than that.
I think they may have had a cellmate prim.
Remember that one? There was that one
on one. You turn me up a little bit.
There was that one. I might
have owned a lockup guy who, uh,
he had a crazy thank you.
It was a Kentucky one. Yeah,
we had a crazy mullet and remember he was,
he had a really scary stare.
Yeah.
And he told a story about how he had
a cellmate and he didn't like him.
Yeah. So he told the
warden or the guards, like,
I don't want to be soul
mates with this guy anymore.
Like get him out of here and there you
go. Like, you don't get to decide that.
So he just killed him. He goes, guess
what? I'll have some in the morning.
I just decided. Yeah,
that's terrifying. Yeah.
Some of these dudes are pretty wild.
Gosh. Oh, that's why they're locked up.
Yeah. Um, what is this? I
haven't seen this. There's
someone said they discovered a,
what is this I want to share
with you? Oh, and guests.
Donia that's really close to where I
went to college. North Carolina. Hmm.
This is a poop pile in the neighborhood.
Oh, okay. Okay. Let's see how, let's see.
Well, your work in Gastonia,
North Carolina, and uh,
I know Christine's had all
these stats about poop pile,
not and not being a common thing
around here. But, uh, this is the local
poop out here. No. Yes. Stoney wow.
Trees right above us.
You can see it's flour.
This is what we do around here.
Tupac man.
Thank you. Edwin. Let's tar heel.
State mastery is hell Edwin. But again,
I'm not seeing the design that
you describe where it put people,
put steps on the ladder and then there's
it. I had a little more ingenuity,
so I mean, that just looks like
a bunch of sticks and some turds.
Let's switch gears for a second. Uh,
thank you Edwin for filming that. Um,
a lot of people were excited last week.
Uh,
by my tried out video and it ended up
leaving to a real examination of one bit
of dialogue. Yes. Uh, this is big.
Your mom's house news hot debate.
We have been examining this.
Then I made note of the ridiculous amount
of different versions of things people
are hearing. They're really, there really
are a lot. Really? Yeah, I wrote that.
Okay. Oh yeah, yeah. Let's hear
it. Well first I guess let's,
let's replay the audio so of course
it can beat me home. Ya know,
so it's that last bit on, Ya know, right.
Homea now. So piss on me. Beat
me, piss on me. Beat me on me.
I know that last bit. Homing.
Yeah. Really gets to people. Okay.
Yeah. So here is, I'm
going to run through,
these are all the ones that were suggested
at least a few times. It's a few.
The first one which was
suggested the most actually okay.
Is that he's saying home yet and
it's because this is after he says,
um, yeah, uh, you got a friend,
your frank and moving to, right.
So call me out.
So he's saying like homie out to all
your friends is what they're saying. Yes,
homie out Amina.
But then I hear homea now,
right homie on out is what they're, some
people are saying he's saying home. Yeah,
no homie on out,
you know,
like homey on out homie homie on out.
So people heard help a man out. Oh yeah,
of course. When I say these things,
none of them should be heard
clearly because he's in this like,
he's so fired up. Frantic. Yeah.
That he's basically tripping
over the words right now. Sorry.
Will help a man out. Let me hear it again.
Help me out. You know palm. Yeah. No, no,
no, no. That's how some are saying,
hold on man out. How a man out.
Yeah. How a man, oh Ho, Ho, Ho man out.
How a man out on me. I know.
Some people are hearing,
uh,
hold me down. So it's like piss
on me. Beat me, hold me down.
Like he's, you know, I mean Piss,
somebody beat me. Oh Man. No, no,
no. Uh, own me. They in and out. Well,
that's interesting.
Let's people heard on me.
I know a lot of people heard
hollow me out. In other words,
he's saying, hollow me out. Hollow
me out. Maybe. How long me out?
Let me hear it. Oh Man. No,
I think it's how a man out
a, it kept going. People, some of the
people heard whole menu like piss on me.
Beat me that. No, he's
not that creative. No. Um,
the big one that really stood out to me.
I'll tell you which one that I
started to believe I was hearing.
This one was explained to me by someone
is hone me out and to hone something out
means to make a whole bigger.
Let's hear it.
Hone me out. Hone me out. All me.
I know now that would be such
an advanced word for him.
He's not thinking that what?
I threw an effect on it.
That was terrifying. Now here's
what I did right here. Okay.
So here's what I actually believe
to be what he's saying. Okay.
I believe,
and this was suggested by a number
of people that he is actually saying,
I'm home home here now. I'm
home right now. Oh Shit Dude.
That's it. That's that one.
Resonate. And here's why. That's it.
Moments before he gave out his address.
Yeah, that makes sense. And he's like,
I'm home wine now. So he's like
pissed on me. Beat me at home.
Like he's saying to come over home right
now so you can do those things right
now.
I even did an edit where I tried
to split up how fast he says it
home here now.
Yeah.
And it's kind of like I'm a hot
white come back when he steps on it,
like I'm home right now and he's so
hopped up that he can't get the words out
fast enough to just strike home.
So now it's pissed on me,
beat me now try to here home
here, now I'm home here, I'm home
home, Ya know? Oh mere.
Now I'm home and I'm home.
I'm home here now.
Do those things right now I'm
home and I'm here now. Yeah,
that's what he's saying. But he, that's
what he's saying. He's too frantic.
You know home.
You know I'm here now.
I'm home on here now and that and that
makes sense actually with his accent and
his hair. Would you want to say is piss
on me? Beat me. I'm home right now.
Come on over it now. It's my address.
It makes total sense. I think that is
all me. I know I'm home. I'm here now.
Can I tell you something?
I rarely get my mind blown like I'm,
my mind is blown because I
would never have heard that,
but once you point that out,
that makes it,
it makes sense in the context of
the other parts of the message.
I was impressed by it. Yeah,
I'm home. I'm here now.
What I was almost more impressed by as
soon as we uploaded last week's podcast
where I shared my version and asked
our listeners to share their version,
try it out.
It started to come in right away.
Go off the fucking fuck.
Good feel black guy and you
want to fuck me moving in.
You can move in. You got to fucking,
I need to be fucked a lot, man.
You get free food for your
rent. Everything else, man.
This dude man in jail,
homeless.
You're thug and want to come and move in.
Your friend can move
into man for your rent.
You to listen to CUNY puts some.
He beat me.
You see me on a come over today
and try it out. Try it out man.
If you're my building, try not. You
want to fucking piss on my try now
man. I'm looking for hardcore
guys and we didn't want to do it.
I want him to deliver white
trash. Come dump. What's? Fuck.
Hey,
great.
Oh Wow. That was Alex. Um,
I won't let them all play out in detail
obviously, but that was stellar. But yeah,
clay here in my building.
Fuck fuck good. Yeah,
this is creepy in the lines of, that is
perfect. Again with the previous guy,
terrible lighting.
They did it way better than I did with a
production value chest hair showing the
weird background. Fantastic. Great work
guys. Production values too, right?
Got It. And you want to fuck me
at 23 buildings? One, two, eight,
seven keys under the front mat.
I mean unit 12 you want to move in?
You can move it up, man.
I need to get fuck, fuck
clay is going on
some black females. He swiped it. Well,
all right.
This is an interpretation.
Fuck fuck girls got
the rabbit on the head.
I hadn't seen that.
What's the ribbon doing that
ribbon, Mike. Thanks Mike.
Come over my house. 24 whatever.
You got to come over. Fuck me.
Cause I think fuck man,
this is great deal man.
I don't care if you're homeless added
jails. So you just got to fuck me man.
Cause it ain't give a fuck the law.
I'm a white trash piece of shit.
Big Black Guy in Brooklyn
and you wanna fuck him.
Barely say I know Morgan
half hit me up man.
I'll be out there shaking my little
white hole picks on me. Okay,
you got fucking dog friends at fucking
also like the fuck I got a little white
lip.
You want to rip my ass
my ass. That's Dana. Dana.
I've took some artistic license on this
interpretation but what works really
well? I like it. It's so dark.
You can barely see this one.
That's hilarious
Josh guys.
Well good.
You're hot black guy and you
want to flunk me at 2,395
when man, but you got leaking fucks
a lot, man. You get free food,
free reign of the necessary
right man from jail, homeless.
You want to come move in your
frank and Logan Movement.
You get a lease in to keep this on me.
That's great.
You know what I would love to see
as a stage version of this like a,
like a really amazing actor doing this.
Like uh,
like Jeremy Irons. Yeah.
Christopher Walken. Really,
really talented to like, I mean
these are great. These are fantastic.
And actually start doing when,
when guests come in here,
we should start having our guests, uh,
do a cold reading and do the monologue.
Yeah, I think so too. No
prep. That should is so funny.
I do watching other people do it
now. Yeah, it's so it's, you see,
you really get to see the absurdity of
his request and the absurdity of his mind
and how sick he is and, and then just
how ridiculous the whole thing is.
But I think you're right that it's a,
I'm here. I'm home right now, home here.
Now I'm home here now. That's what he's
saying. Here's only beat me at home.
Where are it? You can do it
right now. Yeah. Fuck me right
now. Uh, that makes sense.
Contextually it does make sex says,
and he goes, uh, one guy goes, I'm in.
If you're in the building. Yeah. Does
he say that? Yeah, he does. Yeah.
So he's saying I building and trial
child. Yeah. Yeah. I'm, I'm home here.
I'm hearing now I'm here. I know.
Yeah. That's the accident. Is that a,
is it a New York or a movie?
You can move in.
We're here right now. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
No, I don't think he's in New York.
I think it's more like a Midwest movie
can move in and then you can move in.
Yeah. I'm here. I'm here right now.
I think that, yeah. Uh, well you are the
master. I mean you lived in these places.
I'm looking for hardcore guys.
If you want to move in you can move in,
but you got to fuck the
yeah, it's really crazy.
You know, you're in jail,
homeless or around your thug.
These clips sometimes you know, you never
know when they stopped giving. Yeah.
And this one has just been a fount
of just giving and giving and giving.
What a wonderful, what a one. I wish
we had his name is his real name. Yeah.
I don't know.
I can live without knowing his name.
Oh Man. Yeah. Like great job. Thanks
for sending those in. Um, oddly enough,
I don't think we got a female submission.
Really?
Hell are you saying no women? Maybe
there is. I don't know. I haven't,
I haven't checked my,
just let blue band send them then
let this be a call out to everybody.
We need a female
version of the moving. You can
move in, try it out. Um, or a clip.
Provide us with a new clip of a woman
acting completely insane and hopped up on
math and requesting decks and
seconds and stuff. Yeah, let's,
let's get a woman clip. I mean,
no, if a woman does the video,
she's probably a little scared that it's
Debbie take taking kind of seriously.
Yeah. You know what I mean? Well, no, I
mean, let's find a new clip. I hear you.
I hear you. I like to see them.
You go move when you're moving.
You're moving a man. That was
great. That was really fun.
I really was. Hey, did we mention, I
got to mention real quick. Yeah. Um,
you know, I dunno if you know Cardi
B. Yeah. My favorite singer of course.
Uh, Diala I, yeah, I make money moves,
got a new album out and doing really well.
She is just killing that. Yeah. Anyway.
Bodak yellow.
It's her big song playing old songs,
but she's, she's just, she's
doing so well right now. Anyway,
she and I planned our pregnancies
at the same time and, uh,
she's doing July as well. I didn't
realize that. Yeah, we should, uh,
we should give her the heads up.
Yeah, I was thinking on Twitter.
Maybe if you guys could let her know
that her baby is due the same time as the
famous comedian,
Christina p,
that would be amazing if,
you know,
the way we got Gloria
Stefan's attention to,
to talk about she came on our
show and our show. What if, uh,
you guys hit Cardi B of so much about
the fact that she's doing Christina's do
that. She's like, Yo, who the
fuck Christina Pete. Well,
how would it fuck cause she,
yeah, she's got that accent.
I'd be mine and my own business and
I opened my Twitter album. Yeah.
That would be amazing. Hit we
you, who the fuck is Jamar?
You Tag Cardi B be like, Hey
Cardi B, we should it be,
should we ask her? No. Did you know
Cardi B? Did you know it's pretty cool.
Your due dates, the same
Christina beer. Yeah.
How cool of you to get pregnant
the same time as she is. So,
uh, it's, I am Cardi B by those
wizard is her hands her handle?
I am Cardi B so it hit her up and be like,
um,
are you guys going to have your
babies in the same room? Yeah.
Yeah. Just make any reference to
Christina being pregnant with her.
So just be like, Hey,
I didn't know, uh, the,
you're giving birth the same
time as Christina p. Yeah.
Did you plan to have the baby at
the same time as Christina piece?
Hmm.
Are you going to have a, a baby party
with Christina p with the families?
Do or would you have baby
showers together? What's
happening? We're going to, yeah,
she's on the east coast. I'm on the
west coast. Let's make it happen. Uh,
check out this guy.
Just,
this is the kind of guy I could see
you getting like rolling your eyes at,
I think this is on the train
or something somewhere.
So this guy from me once he taught
at prostitutes pee in his mouth,
so I think he's drunk on a subway
or a train or something. Okay.
Drinking mouthwash.
This guy, that guy just reading is down.
Don't even look, you know what that is?
That's big city experience right there.
That's when you have been,
you know that if you go like that, very
exciting. You're going to antagonize,
you're going to provoke. He's like,
I'm just repeating what somebody says.
Shit like that on a train
next to you. No. Yeah.
You act like you don't hear a fucking
thing and you just record them through
your bicycle.
Yeah.
Okay.
This clip for me is really about the
guy sitting next to him was great.
Trying not to laugh right now. That's
fantastic. Yeah. Yeah. It's like, what is,
what is my life,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah. He started to laugh here.
You started to laugh at the end.
He broke the guy next to him.
Yeah. It's um hmm. That's a,
that's a, that's an interesting,
what would you really need
a prostitute for that?
That's to me, that seems like an easy
ask the wife or the girlfriend. What? No,
it's not. You could ask me to do,
I'll try and I'll try it. All right.
I'll pee in your mouth will
be on your fucking face.
Not something most people
ask there. Oh No, I don't.
I don't take offense to that. For me. It's
easy peasy. I'm already paying anyway.
Um, yeah, I wouldn't care. I
mean, that's cool. Have you,
but I think most people that are,
that's kind of a,
I was, I not horrible. I mean it's kind
of advanced. I don't think most people,
you know, some people are in the p but
aren't most, most probably people aren't.
I'm like, will you pee in my
mouth? And they probably wouldn't.
I don't think they would just be like, oh,
that's a good girlfriend has, but also,
do you think he has a girlfriend?
That's probably what we should lead with.
Do you think he's just like, yeah, I'll
just ask my girlfriend for that. No,
I guess, no, I guess not.
He seems a little drunk too
during the day little, yeah,
it's dude is fucking hammered. It
looks like it's the morning. Yeah.
Yeah. Huh, Huh.
And
go
oof. Really drunk, you know? Let's
see if it says where this was,
I don't know if this was,
just says that he's the guy
I let prostitutes. PMR mouth.
I like the Vietnam office.
Yeah. The world is full of colorful
people. Yeah. So you would be like,
you're on board. If I'm like, I want you
to give a shit. You know what I'm saying?
Like if you're in a relationship
with somebody and that's their thing,
that's easy to accommodate that.
That's not, I'll be honest.
That does not intrigue me.
Why not?
I've never been into urine.
I don't like the smell of it,
Daryl. I know, but I just,
you know, most of the time you smell
pee. I don't go like, oh have a smell.
Pas excited. I'm like, this
smells like Piss, you know?
But it's like that guy that McAfee
guy lets people shit in his mouth.
That's to me different ballgame.
It is a different ball game.
It's a way different ballgame and those
people should be put somewhere else.
But it's mental.
But my point of bringing that up
is just that you know the smell.
How do you deal with the smell? The
Pismo? Yeah. Let's put things in context.
Your P, this is what the fourth
coffee you've had this morning. Yeah.
Second you drink nothing. First of all,
the water champ. Let's look right now.
Who's got delicious clear water
on their t side of the table.
Who's drinking mostly water and
a cup. Okay, that's iced coffee.
That's your second. And that's
a venti. That's not a small,
so the reason your piece smells horrendous
is because you're not hydrating your
mouth. It's smells like a brick of
coffee. Uh, my pee smells great. No,
it smells like an entire graph of
coffee being poured into a toilet.
I'm looking for Posey.
If anyone out there.
My p does it smell a lot?
Because it's pretty clear cause I
drink a lot of water. You see? No,
I drink a lot of water. No you don't.
Yes I do. I drink mostly water. Water.
Now Liars having a coffee. That doesn't
mean I don't drink mostly water.
I never see you drink water. I only see
you drinking brown coffee. Oh my God.
You're such a liar. You're such
a psycho liar. I never see it.
You cannot be trusted. That's what
I know for sure. P of my mouth.
You're a fucking liar.
You wouldn't want me to pee in your mouth.
No nastiest shit. I went. Okay, well
you don't have to drink it. Does he?
Does he drink it or he just,
that's what I'm wondering.
He doesn't drink it though, right? How
do you know he doesn't drink it? Well,
does the macafee guy eat the poo
poo or he just, I don't know.
We act like I fucking hang out with
these guys. You Watch the documentary?
They talk about whether he eats it?
No.
Why does nobody asks the pressing
questions in these films? I don't know.
That's like the biggest question. Do you
want to get pissed in your mouth? No. Why?
I'm not interested.
I've never thought why don't you let me
pee in your mouth and you can masturbate
at the same time? Why not? Excuse
me. But the next time you masturbate,
do you mind if I, what does she
say? I Dunno. I remember that lady.
She's like to ask for Anal Lingus.
Do you mind if I
um, it's a very specific
thing. Fetish? Yeah.
You want to try it? No. How
do you know you won't like it?
I know I won't like it. What
part of it? No, I won't like it.
It's too hot. It's weird. I
honestly, it's not the smell.
It's the temperature I think would
freak me out. Maybe it'll turn you on.
I don't think so either.
You could roll around in it.
Why don't you lay in the tub?
Live someone pay in your mouth.
I'm not averse to having
your fluids on me.
Like obviously I don't care about that.
I really do think it's the
warmth of the P and my mouth.
That would make me want to vomit.
Cause it's like body temperature
except your ps really hot.
Actually I think your p is like 105
degrees because it's so brown and thick.
No, it's, it's like that guy's calm like
the four stroke p. That's cause it's,
there's no water and it's just so chunky.
And it was like Brown chunks come out.
No, it's the temperature
more than anything. Um,
and your piece specifically
smells very pungent, very strong,
very strong smell.
When I go pee on your pee in the
middle of the night and I smell it,
it's so dark. It's so brown with
the P is like a brown. Cool.
It's clear. It's clear
as day. Oh No. Oh No.
Let's go take a pee challenge right now.
I'll fucking show you my piece.
Clear years is Brown. No, it's not.
You say stupid shit nonstop and no one
calls you on course. I say stupid shit.
This is your mom's house, baby. This
is the platform for stupid shit.
I drink nothing but water
and coffee all day. Okay.
Then why does it smell like coffee?
Only it doesn't. That's what I'm saying.
You're a fucking liar. Show strong. Okay.
Your P's mostly red. Okay. Red p.
Yeah. Right now being pregnant
from blood. Yeah. Okay.
That makes no sense. But yeah. No,
and I actually, I'll be honest,
you scared me with how little
water you've been drinking.
I'm being totally serious.
I see you drinking soda,
drinking alcohol,
but I don't see you drinking water.
I'm serious. Okay. Okay. Listen,
can I read an email that came in
from our friend Matt on these coasts?
I'm sure he says the sons,
they were having a,
a family discussion and it's kind of an
interesting topic and I definitely think
it's appropriate for our show.
Okay. So what'd you do this?
Once you take this offer,
it's a would you rather?
Okay.
From this moment until the end of your
life all of course I'm fucking blind.
All the food you eat will taste like the
best version of whatever it is you're
eating. So if you're eating pizza, it
will taste like the best pizza ever.
If you're eating snoozers,
it's the best snu she ever.
But every time you fart,
it will smell 1% worse than the last part.
You may with no limit on how smelly
your farts will become over time.
So once you accept the deal, the next
fart you make will be the baseline.
Do you make this deal? Why or why not?
Um, so thank you Matt for submitting this.
Both things happen in this scenario.
So you get the best food ever,
but every time you fart it gets
1% worse than the last time.
I mean, who would not
take that deal? Well,
cause your farts are going to be
horrendous. By the end of your life.
It's going to be napalm.
Who Cares? Who Cares?
I care. You're fortunate already bad. And
that there's no such thing as good fart,
so it's already smells disastrous.
You're saying it's going to smell worse,
but you get the best taste
ever whenever you eat anything.
I mean this is an easy one. Yeah,
but it's not for me. Here's why
is that I don't want my food to taste
the best ever. Cause then I get fat.
Just fucking whatever. Check
yourself regulate. It's fine. Yeah,
but food tastes even
better than it does now.
You know how hard it is for me just
to maintain and not when I'm pregnant.
It's hard. But I mean how could
you turn that? You wouldn't,
he's saying that if you have a bite of
a cookie, if you have a piece of paper,
I don't want it to be
the best tasting ever.
Cause I be the fattest person ever.
No. Yeah, no. You could just stop you.
There's some things you
eat now that are amazing.
You don't just keep going crazy on
them. We can. You have self restraint.
1% worse.
Fart every time is terrible.
You won't be able to
stew in your own baby.
You won't even be able to sit
in your own fart. Yeah, you,
but you'd work out a system. You'd be
like, oh, I got a far coming in and you,
you go outside and you'd run every time
you have to fart or something and right
behind you. Yeah. You'd just
be like, I got to Fart in the,
you'd run away from your smell,
but what about me? Like you're not,
you don't think that'll bother me
over time and getting them outside,
running away from it. But that's a lie.
Okay, let's, let's be realistic here.
You're not going to do that.
I just give you a mask.
You think I want to sleep with a mask on
set for sleep just for the moment when
I Fart, dude. But you've,
here's when your farts mostly happen at
nighttime when we're laying in bed in
the middle of the night, middle
of the night mornings, dude,
you far at like four in the morning,
super loud and then you think it's the
best thing that's ever happened to me.
And I'm like, oh I can, I'll
start old and I wake up,
you fight in the morning to first thing.
So what?
What am I supposed to be worried
about that it smells bad, dude.
So when you think I want
to smell that far. Yeah,
but I'm getting these great tastes.
I don't care about your tastes.
I care about your farts.
Yeah,
but I'm saying that I would take it
because I want to have those great tastes
and I don't care if it smells a little
bit worse every time you're going to ruin
your marriage. Why would I ruin it? Look
how bad your dad's farts smell. Yeah,
those are bad.
That's really bad.
They have taken up this offer.
Somebody may have given him this offer.
I mean his farts smell like this offer.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's a life Roner like
your dad's farts are just tear.
They clear out movie theaters.
You was fucking, you would
survive. I would survive,
but I wouldn't be happy. And
why? Why would you be unhappy?
Because just to smell a little
rotten fart every now and then.
Every now and then.
My life is your farts.
The other day we were in the kitchen and
you force my hand on your underwear as
you farted on my hand. Do you think
that was nice? I remember that. Yeah.
I felt the vibration.
We're doing the cool one where I uh,
I played with my butt sheet as I farted.
I remember that one. Yep.
That was pretty cool.
I just feel like I deal with a lot of
your farts and for them to smell worser.
Why worser is not, it's
not cool for me. It's fine.
I feel like it's fine. We'll have fun with
your second wife. Let's talk about her.
I think she's like,
I think your second wife is going to be
a Dalmatian cause second wives usually
are. Yeah. We've been
studying some second wives.
We know some people that are on their
second wife likes showbiz second wives.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the guy gets a little cash,
he has a midlife crisis.
He dumps the first wife and the kids and
the family and then runs off with just
the fucking skanky.
IEST dumbest it happens.
Happens a lot. So you need a few
times. Yeah. And it's, you know,
of course it's admirable. Everybody
goes, that's awesome. Um, but yeah,
I mean like what, who, who do you, how
do you see it playing out for me? Um,
I definitely think that your second
wife is going to be way younger.
I'd be like, Hey, let's start
with like age. We're going to go,
this happens probably like, what,
five, six years from now in your mind.
The kids are grown.
Yeah, they're fine. They're fine.
They're doing great in elementary school.
And then you, you know, you're
a big movie star, big celebrity,
one of your ingenue costars she just
turned 20. She's like the new hot Winnie.
She's 20.
She's 20 years old and a blah.
I know you like blondes and
just really not demanding,
like not smart. That's all
right. That's like the key,
the key to it from what
I've seen, uh, on these, uh,
these second wife. Yeah. A
lot, a lot less of this chat.
A lot less opinions,
no opinions,
no things you have to do today.
No. You know, there's no,
no schedule or of course,
and that's what I seen that these,
the midlife guy goes towards it.
It's like, oh, this is great.
Then he sometimes has to remember that.
Then there's going to be
no opinions, no pain, no,
no conversations that are going to be
decent. She's got to say stuff like wow,
bay. But she'll call you babe
a lot, baby. Oh my God, baby.
I love this.
Might have hair extensions,
a big fake tits and she's just going to
say things I have to a big fake tits, so.
Right. I mean, she does. She's the second
wife. They all do. They all have second.
I think. I don't die. I
don't think so. You know? Um,
wow. This is awesome. Like those are
the phrases you're going to hear a lot.
Yeah. Yeah. Wow. Oh, I love you babe.
Yeah, Dalmatian Talk. Yeah.
The second wife has to be way dumber
than the first. Oh, definitely. That's,
that's part of what you're looking for.
Way less qualified as a human.
It's just like a stupid girl and she's
just like, your kids are so cute.
Tell him I keep, my kids are not good.
This feels more girlfriend then
wife though. No, that's the point.
See that's the thing is that it should
be just a girlfriend like and then what?
Then I'm like,
Oh fuck no you love it because you've
had the first wife who was all these,
you know, words, words, words, ideas,
orders and you're so over it and upset
that like the Dalmatians a relief cause
you can just do what you want.
Come and go as you please.
You are singing to me right
now. I love it. When um,
how do you prevent this from happening?
Cause it sounds like just how do
I prevent you got it. He tell me.
I don't know. I just, that's great.
20 Ted, stupid as, as all get out and,
and like my kids spend a lot
of time with her and they her,
oh that's the other parts of things
like emotionally she's about the
same level. She's like I got,
I got them slime, we did a slime party
and I'm like, what's a slime party?
All the kids are doing it.
And she rented out a room at the
chuck e cheese or whatever. Fucking,
we all had slime party and
she's the coolest. I'll be like,
cause she knows all this stuff
cause she's a fucking drum.
Shandy said the store's name.
Yeah, she's awesome. She had the, she
had, he let me get hair extensions.
Shandy tech me to the salon. No, no.
Shanti Shanti and we'll get them acrylic
nails when they're like seven my boys.
Oh that's right. We didn't want them
girls. He noticed it but she, she wanted,
she wanted a whore up your daughters,
if you had writers spoil them,
let them do what they want and you
have to hear about how great Shandy is.
You think you would just
tolerate it? Oh my God. No.
I would go to a mental hospital like I
would if you did that shit to me and our
family. Yeah. I would just
be institutionalized. I think
they would just give up.
Oh my God, how it works. How do
I get this done? This is great.
I would just be, I would be a
shell if you did this to me. Oh,
that's what that second wife,
so what's second husband like?
Usually a second husband.
Women shut it down.
I think women, if you, if you had
this happened to you sometimes,
here's how it goes to waste.
The 50 year old woman just either
shuts it down like Jane Fonda,
she's older than that 50 but yeah,
she just came out and she was like,
shut it down like women and go the other
way where they're like, I'm over it.
I'm never getting married again. I don't
need a vagina. I'm fine. I'm in menopause.
Don't touch me. I'm having hot
flashes. Or they go hypersexual. Yeah.
And they're like,
I'm going to adult con this weekend.
I'm going to touch vibrators and,
and I'm a MILF guys and they really
advertise themselves as a Melph.
Maybe you do that. Maybe you start a new
site. Yeah. W from foreign ministers.
I just convert it to Christina.
gilt.com get off. I'm like, grandma,
you're going to be some point.
God
No,
but then I have to lose like 50
pounds and get Lipo and fixed my tits.
If you want to go the hypersexual
and then I go hypersexual which work?
I know you, you'd be like, I don't want
to do all that shit. I'm so lazy. I,
you'd be like, no, no, no,
no. Shut it down. Shut it
down. Uh, but then, you know,
I'd find some like age gap, Love
Shit, some 28 year old loser,
you know, playing the video games and
I, and I would just take care of him.
That's the equivalent baby. The
Dalmatian wife. That's what I can't see.
You go in that route. I might, I mean,
what a video game guy. Well, I'm, I'm the,
I'm the breadwinner and he's just like,
I play a bit down.
Do you think you would like
the Dalmatian life course?
I'm talking about something
more reasonable for you.
Of course I went to Dalmatian
wife. That's it. But that's not,
that's six years away. Maybe you would
not be a real tolerate six years away. Uh,
how stupid she is. Cause she would say
dumb things. That's true. Oh my God.
All the time. She's so
embarrassing. I would have uh,
uh, dinners, but I'd be like, uh, no.
I was just going to be me and my friends
cause it would be other couples and
they'd be like, where's your Dalmatian?
I'm like, oh, she had choir practice.
But you know,
your other friends would talk so much shit
about your down nationwide. Of course.
Oh my God.
It would never be their go
goto gossip things worse.
We've seen Tom's new wife.
She's so, she's so dumb.
Christina was so much smarter
than her. Yeah. But then Berge
yeah, no, I know a lot.
Um, you know, I might get into some like
real kinky stuff next. You do. You know,
this is something, I dunno how
much I could tolerate it. This,
this is so weird to me
that people really do this
Peter Pan,
I think it's so weird to me. So this
is some, a woman likes to be babies.
She's a grown woman,
likes to be treated like a baby and
he pretends to be her dad, dad. Kay.
This is definitely for doctor.
It's,
here's what strikes me even more besides
the obvious is that we're actually with
a toddler all the time.
So the fact that this is somebody's choice
to be like this is really stands out
of stupid,
stupid or damaged cause yeah,
I think what happened is some so much
trauma like I bet you this one is sexual
trauma and she wants, she needs
to regress or something. Okay.
Cause she's not embracing adult sexual.
This is why you know those a
porno girls talking baby talk,
that's sexual molestation. How does this
Guy Bang her? Cause you know he's tall,
he's talking to her like a baby all the
time, you know, and then you're going to,
he's like, he's like, okay, we
read our book, you're ready.
It goes sleep now booboo.
And then, then she's like, Oh why
the fuck? It's like that's really it.
Do they have intercourse? I
Dunno, let's get through it.
I've men who moved Emily and already
crumbling through the power dreary air
but not really cause I'm fine.
Oh see there you go. Ready? Just to
start. So he is 11 years older than her,
so he doesn't mind taking on,
I guess the, the paternal role.
You know what always stands out to me
about something like this is the effort,
the amount of effort out. Good talking to
you. Like you're fucking baby right now.
Again, I could do this, you
know, I can do this for a date.
Like if I went out with someone,
they're like,
talk to me like a baby or
something and be like, all right.
But then at the end of the
day I'd be like, there's no
way I could do this again.
I don't even think I could last a date.
And this is so wackadoo.
I mean this chick's got so many
fucking metal problems and so does he,
but maybe he likes the dependency of
it. She's totally, you know a baby.
It's so big.
It's so sick.
Yeah.
Oh my God. He's going to be like,
you have your shoes. You know,
we got to go out with shoes. She needs
something. She can't put them on.
She needs her daddy.
Lg By definition
is daddy don little girl.
And it is a subsection of Bdsm,
which is a part of kink. I was just
discovering things about the community,
learning a bit more about it.
I decided to um,
try it out and I've just loved
it ever since. It's just me
try it out. So this, this grinds or
crank, it's really gets her going.
This is a second. I
mean, I guess, you know,
I'd like to encourage people
to find out what they like.
I got to tell you this.
I don't want the adult baby diaper thing.
I don't get either.
I don't,
I don't understand what the turn on
is about being an infant or acting.
It's really, that's your wires
are crossed, man is some flex
and wire crossed shit.
There are a lot of people in the
community that do this sexually. Um,
and I'm not one of those
people completely, no
sexual lifestyle for me. Oh,
thank God.
Okay.
Okay. So now that, that's more
so that means that she does fuck,
but only when she's out of Cara. Thank
God I ain't, you know what I mean?
I think the role,
I understand the role playing.
Maybe she's healing some childhood trauma
or something, but the fucking, the fire,
the guy, oh my God. Look like,
how's your girlfriend? Good.
What do you guys do for fun?
Well, she pretends to be five.
We go to the park. Yeah. Do play dough.
Max First told me that
she was this lifestyle.
She had shown me the videos that she
was watching. She showed me a copy.
I know I'm a Jesus showing her how to
count and uh, going over the alphabet.
You're like, what? Yeah.
Push her on the swings.
There's a teeter totter or she could
spell her name. She could spell my name.
Uh, could you spell the dog's name? Yeah,
we're really in a Thomas the train right
now. Can you count all at tenant back?
Does your girlfriend? Yeah, she likes
Peppa the pig. I saw that. Yeah.
That's a good one.
Was it?
She was watching,
she was eating these babies
snacks and I think that's when we,
that's when we had the
conversation about it.
No, you mean this fucking
asshole. Nice though, right?
It's Cosby sweater and his ear plug his
butt plugs in his ears. And all this,
but he's a nice guy. Is he a nice guy
for doing this? To hear this psycho?
I think so.
What's his deal?
Went down on more hardcore
versions of the DLG subset,
but for a lot of, for a lot
of people is nonsexual. It's,
and for us it's nonsexual.
Do you
imagine getting this shit?
I know it's nuts isn't to just show you
the really is someone for everyone now.
There is man. It's the inner
how lucky that she found him.
I would say because most guys, if she
was dating and she was like, I go,
I, I learned blue sky blue and
those, you know, he'd be like,
did it and then this is a square. They
look the fuck are you doing right now?
Come wipe me. Yeah. I mean this is
like other level. Could you imagine?
I would love to see these two playing in
the park. I'm like, what is happening?
How weird must it get?
Cause she said that a lot of in this
lifestyle do a sexual play on this.
Yeah, that's what I'm, I'm wondering
what the deal is there. That's real.
I think that's, that's trauma.
Absolutely right. It's gotta be,
you're reenacting the trauma. Oh
fuck. I mean there's, there's no way
I have a little, a lot of the time,
especially when we're at home. Cool.
When we're just relaxing and I'm with
him. I'm little when I want to be, um,
I'm a little when it's right to be,
but of course it's,
it's not something that like I cannot
some trouble like public, you know,
I don't just randomly like shout daddy
because that's involving other people in
something that they didn't
know. So she's smart. Okay.
Yeah. She understands boundaries.
She understands indoor, outdoor.
The is fun for her. She, yeah.
You know what? Now that I
see her, she seems rational.
Yeah. And it just brings her joy and
then, you know, good for her. Yeah.
But she definitely needs to make an
appointment with a therapist and, and uh,
get on that. She really likes
pretending to be a little girl,
might want to talk to somebody.
Daddy takes care of me,
but I also take care of him.
We take care of each other.
And I think having that nurturing aspect
to the relationship really makes it
strong.
Okay. You know, this could be growth,
this could be a wife number two. Oh boy.
It is like it is the same thing.
Yeah. For me basically, you know,
dependent dumb,
dumb.
Now this, this chick needs
serious mental counseling.
See if she's still under this.
And is there anything that just just
like going to a shrink once a week,
twice a week maybe for her will just
do wonders. Yeah. I think getting out,
I think this discussion would, she needs
some professional. We're out a lot. Yeah.
I have an extensive list of rules,
but the main ones are no tantrums.
I'm no saying no and those are the
two that I'm not that great at.
If I break a rule,
then I get timeouts.
I just have to sit here in the corner
and stare at the wall and do nothing.
Yeah.
What the fuck is this all about?
What's going on?
Why are you doing this?
What the fuck is going on as a
ride? But Hey, you know what?
It sounds like she's a pretty rational
human and she knows what, Hey,
this is my fun time.
I I boundaries and I do this in the house.
Explain this lifestyle in terms of a
little whose lifestyle is kind of like a
coloring book where she hands me the
lines and I can just fill them in with
whatever we're calling
on one. Oh boy. Yeah.
What is a fire? She's five and she's
still drinking out of a sippy. Yeah.
Get on your advanced sippy stuff.
Well,
she can drink out of a cup by now at five.
Yeah.
Ellis was the same exact to sip it. You
stopped that one. He stopped this. Yeah.
To go to school. I mean they don't
even let you bring that in. Vulnerable
and so open in little space that
that's where I want to keep it.
Like it's a safe place and it's a place
that we share together on the day,
Christ and the bass
that would wear so quick right
now. I know. And she said like,
oh, don't worry. I'll be like, hey,
can you stop doing that?
That'd be so bad at being that that,
but that's also the the time we live
in this whole safe place. Horse Shit.
This is my safe place. I think you'd
be, we'll fucking weird is I want, yeah.
What is wrong with these?
We will have fun decency anymore.
You know what I'm saying?
Like can we just go back to repressing
our desires like a normal society and be
contributing members just for press this
shit and go do something else with your
life. That's good advice. You know what
I mean? Go, go contribute to society.
That's good advice. Press desires
are good because they make you,
you sublimate them through other things.
This, I know you're going to get a kill.
Fucking won a Nobel prize. You Psycho.
You're going to have some money.
Great thoughts. All right, I'll go ahead
and I'll read this. Okay, so hungry,
I'll read this to you is an
email that came in. Hey moms.
I been with my boyfriend for almost
two years and as he is getting more
comfortable with me, he's also getting
grocer. But one year into dating.
We went on a two week long trip,
a few days into the trip.
I noticed that he hadn't taken a shower
yet and he insisted that he showered
after I'd fallen asleep.
I believe them at first,
but as the first week went by and noticed
none of the hotel towels removing from
where I had got put them and the shampoo
and soap hadn't moved the next week he
got a really bad sunburn and use that as
an excuse to not shower for the rest of
the trip.
Turns out he didn't shower for a month.
Fast forward to a year later,
we now live together and he was
showering every few days at first,
but now he just washes his hair and
his junk maybe once every two weeks.
I confront him about it all the time and
tell him that he smells like dirty skin,
but he just laughs about it.
I've tried to get him to shower with me,
but he always makes up an excuse.
Also,
he has the same bottle of soap in
the shower since I first met him.
I worry that I'm starting to not notice
the smell and that our whole apartment
smells like him. He is also
an athlete. So that makes,
yeah.
Any suggestions to help
me make him shower. Also,
what is the longest you've gone without
shower out and what is an acceptable
amount of time to go without
one? I can't go two days. Nope.
Thanks for taking the time to
read this. Love the show. Hannah.
I mean, do you want to start? Well,
I mean, you know, obviously there,
there is probably some root issue
involved in this being something for him.
In other words,
this doesn't,
most people do shower that are normal,
healthy,
functioning in society.
Yeah. So, uh, I, you know,
there might be something
tied to this guy's childhood.
Oh,
I might go even something more basic.
I had a roommate in college that had
severe skin psoriasis or Eczema or
something, some kind of
skin condition. Yeah.
And so showering for him was rare as
well because it would aggravate the skin
condition. So he might have
like a medical, I don't know.
Well she would pick up on that.
I think that'd be,
if I like to just be adverse to taking
showers. It's, it's definitely unusual.
Especially someone that works out a lot.
Yeah. This is a psychological issue too.
I think so. Yeah. Cause I mean
that's one of the main things.
I mean I'm going to go to the gym
here in a minute and it's like, oh,
you come back and you're soaking
wet and yeah, sometimes you know,
you get distracted and it starts to dry,
but you feel that,
that dry sweat on you.
And
you know what? I am, I shower every
day no matter how horrible I feel.
I think the only times I've ever skipped
is when I've been really ill with a
fever. Even when I gave birth.
Yeah. I think I showered, uh,
the next I've been very sick
and missed a couple days.
You know what I'm talking
to. But to set us, yeah.
Um,
with like a,
a viral or bacterial infection
or something that vomiting
and you're just like,
um, and you know, if you have
shakes because you, you know,
your temperatures swinging a
couple of days, but being healthy,
I mean the longest would be
skipping a day because of, yeah.
Because of whatever
scenario, you know, a day,
a day.
But I am so fanatic about my body
is failing clean and feeling fresh.
I just feel greasy and oily.
Who doesn't like that?
I love the post clean failing best.
A lot of times I'll do it.
I've gone through, you know,
a lot of times I shower right before
bed if I have a long day. Yeah.
It's like I'm about to get
in bed. I was like, no,
I'm going to shower first shower,
then get in bed.
Feels good. It feels good.
Yeah. I mean, listen,
I don't know how this isn't a deal breaker
for this woman sexually. Oh my God.
Because you, uh, uh, just as a
partner I think as a courtesy,
like his dick and balls
can't smell great you,
so he does it once every two weeks.
Yeah. And not only that, it's,
it can give you infections
to UTI. Uh, you know,
they're not new.
Do
together as a couple of years.
I would sit down, I'm serious.
I would go for this. I always say,
look, you know, I, you know, I love you.
You know I'm with you. Yeah,
let's just talk about it. Yeah.
Why is she just straight up?
Yeah.
Let's talk about what's going on and
he's going to be like, wait, what? What?
Let's just be straight up about it.
Just tell me so that I know,
what is your aversion to showers?
Like what's going on, what's going on?
And then he, he might be like,
no, I'd be like, no, no, no.
Like we've been together for a couple of
years. We lived together. So you know,
I'm in to you.
Yeah.
But I just want to know and then maybe
you get a little bit under the surface.
See,
but I think if it is a psychological
trauma or some kind of an issue,
a lot of people don't even know what
that thing is consciously. The commerce,
like the conversation starter
is going to get something going.
Can I tell you as a woman what I would do?
Uh,
I think the trick is to get in with
dudes is sexual stuff and be like,
look, I love you. I want
to keep fucking Yale.
I can't fuck you if your Dick
Smells. Yeah, that's true. I mean,
and you can also do the, if if reason
doesn't work, you can lead like,
like basically set up that sex is
going to happen and he's like, yeah.
And they'd be like, look, go shop. But
see that's just going to get it done.
I know it's a long, I'm saying the
longterm discussion needs to happen. Like,
excuse me, like you're saying. Yeah,
but she needs to maybe make an incentive
for him if he's not willing to,
cause she says she's asked,
right.
I think she needs to incentivize him
a little bit and maybe the sexist.
Yeah, I'd want to know. I'd be like,
oh, I really want to know what's up.
Sounds horrible.
I mean that especially if he's exercising,
that's really not cool.
Then again, there I just,
people who don't shower frequently,
who it's their thing.
I mean,
I have relatives who are not big bathers
and I'm talking going days and days and
days and I, you know,
I don't know that hygiene man,
I got have it. I can't stand it.
If my hair is greasy and
I'm smelly or like I can't,
I can't be with someone like that. I
mean, thinking about your, your, your,
your asshole and you're
digging balls and your badge.
Like to me not having a dirty
vagina is like, it's just, I can't,
I cannot, you know what I'm
saying? We'll dude's like, we know.
No, you skip a day. What's
going on in your ball bag?
Of course you run that and you go, oh,
you can smell it and nuts stink. Oh,
of course. I mean, same with women.
It's just sweat. Yeah. I mean,
you've got to get soap in
there. You got it. I mean,
there's no way she can blow this
guy. There's no way. And again,
you can get all kinds of infections from
somebody who's not hygienic down there.
You know, he's one of those guys, you
know sometimes you're out in public,
you're in line at the grocery store and
all of a sudden someone walks by and you
go like, Oh yeah, I get
that. That be oh trail.
You know where you go is so nasty.
They walk around like everything's fine.
You pose a shit so nasty.
That's why people were put Julie,
they cover that shit.
I would that nasty oils and stuff.
I hate it too.
That's another thing I filled out there
for wife number two, no petroleum oil,
no shower all the time, but she
does that. She was wife number two,
wife number two's got all kinds of
time cause she doesn't have a job.
She doesn't really have hobbies.
She just likes to exercise.
This was a, you know, another message
came in. It's pretty funny. Hey jeans.
After a busy morning I took
to my car to take a break,
reclined my seat and listen to
your mom's house while relaxing.
I rolled the window down this beautiful
day and a miss listening to an edit of
Tom and friends in a gay orgy calling a
phone sex line. Remember that prank call?
I noticed through my rear view window,
my female boss who was parked behind
me taking notice of the ungodly sounds
coming from my car after five to 10
seconds of clue listening to the phone,
sex call,
she got in her car and drove off.
I immediately laughed so hard at the
thought of her thinking about how I watch
gay porn on my breaks.
I have since run into her and the
Internet has yet to be addressed.
I want to thank the Mommy's for now
creating this unspeakable tension.
We shall forever hold between us.
That's true.
Cause that that call was really graphic
really long too. Yeah. It was all like,
yeah, I fucking come on me, suck
Mike. It was really, really intense.
It's pretty funny. Yeah. That's great.
You got to try to listen. You know,
with ear buds. Yeah. I
guess roll your windows up.
She's says jeans until the day I die.
The phrase,
try it out has been forever ruined.
I can't hear without fuck me,
piss on me and beat me going,
running through my brain's
when test driving a new car,
getting a new putter or the first time
my wife had been where this swaddle cloth
with my new son. She asked if I
want to and utters that damn phrase.
I'm now holding my son.
All I can hear as a man asked me to
piss him off on him and beat him.
I wonder if it's a first in human history.
Love you Andrew.
We have room and try it out. I just
ruined for me. I mean, I say it just,
it'll come out and then I just, I started
laughing. What are you laughing at? My,
I just try it. I know so many
phrases are destroyed for us.
Yep. Uh, so when tells me to be careful,
I used to be carefree and scratching
my ass all the time. I got a,
then I got a deal. Science assist, uh,
apparently scratched and broke the skin
a bit and allow bacteria to get in over
time and form assist.
I couldn't sit down comfortably.
Had to have surgery to have it
removed and cleaned out. Yeah. Sorry.
This is from scratching too hard. Yeah.
Scratching the crack too hard. Yeah.
You gotta go, he said he did
his finger just to the crack.
Like direct skin skin. Well yeah, I
actually had one of those when I was 19.
I had that, that system is
it from scratching directly?
I got mine from horseback
riding. Ah, fuck horses.
I went horseback riding and I have
a hairy butt. And so you're like,
the whole time you were rubbing, you
know, like that. And then I was like, oh,
this hurts.
And I showed it to a,
it's actually a friend's mom who was a
nurse and she was like, you need to where,
where was it on your butt? The top,
very top of the crack. The middle,
like at the very top. Sure. And then
I went and the guy was like, oh yeah,
you have this thing. And
assisted formed, you know,
started a forum and I was like hurt.
And he's like, yeah, cause uh, like it's
infected now. I was like, oh, I
was totally scared. He gave me,
um, a, uh, what's it
called? Uh, uh, antibiotics.
And that night,
that night,
the cyst exploded,
but it did it in my sleep.
I just woke up and when I, when
I wake up, my buck, my box,
it had ruptured and then dry because
it was in my sleep were all crusty.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And I take them off and there's
like dried blood and says no.
It's just, it's like a little thing like
quarter, no smaller than that even. Yeah.
Nicole. Yeah, I guess it
was all pus and blood.
Who's super nasty. Yeah. That's where
you want me to put my mouth? No,
below that. Lower on lower part
of you thinks that this is okay.
So he's telling you don't scratch so
hard finger is saying be careful because
it's like the same thing as
the horseback riding. You know,
you can shoot everything. Yeah, sure,
sure. Guy. That's why I advocate.
If you've got a butt scratch,
just rub your finger over your underwear.
Do you know what I'm saying? Go through
the don't go under the underwear. Yeah.
Just scratch through your clothing.
Why? So what? Wash your underwear,
right? Sure. Don't touch skin to
skin and then your fingers all dirty.
Some of your Chinese get Terry.
That's what they're for.
Wore a all right.
I got a try it out and we got to
try it out. Um, that's a gene.
What else you got? Anything else? No,
I think I'm good. I'm, I love you.
I love you too.
Um,
we got to get y'all and I'm home.
I'm home here now.
I'm hearing no piss on me.
Beat me home right now.
I'm here. No piss on me. Beat me
home here. Now I'm homeless here now.
I think that's what he's saying,
but I think you're right.
Come home. I'm home. I'm home.
I'm homing now.
I'm home right now.
I think so. I'm now all right.
We've got to run here is
time. Classic Song. Oh my gosh.
And we'll see you next week.
Thanks for listening.
I forget the fourth stroke
gang shirt is a in the store.
A Thompson.
Don't buy that syrupy on my line
or don't support time in this.
Please support me in this.
Don't support this lunacy hygiene.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh,
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
That's
not bad. Not Bad at all. Not
Bad at all at all. At all.